valerant masters one in reykjavik is
just around the corner but for some eu
teams things aren't looking good
fnatic's durkha tested positive for
kovid while brave has been suspended and
fpx as a whole team will not be able to
compete it is a whole lot to get into so
let's get started
all right y'all so if you don't know who
fnatic is they are one of eu's best and
brightest filled with insane duelists
like durka five head shot calling and
theatrics from boaster they're just a
really tight team all around they've
never quite made it to the top making it
to many masters events and even
champions not quite finding their
winning footing now in late january the
team decided to replace doma with a
russian sova player brave af for the
2022 vct season so with brave on the
roster fnatic managed to qualify for
iceland after a gruelling 44-round match
against gambit but after that marathon
qualifier match the team ran into some
big problems brave is from russia and
currently lives there back in february
russia invaded ukraine and is still
waging war on ukrainian soil this
prompted many tournament organizers to
restrict russian players from competing
in their events or even banning them
outright so naturally there are
questions from fans about what this
would all mean for russian esports pros
and durka fielded some of them on stream
if you guys make us and can get brave
out i don't think it will be possible
basically brave is unable to travel to
iceland due to visa issues and travel
restrictions that have stemmed from the
russian invasion of ukraine on march
30th yxo posted a tweet containing dms
allegedly showing brave support for the
russian invasion of ukraine we did an
in-house translation of the russian and
here are some things to note brave
allegedly says at one point
russia ukraine and belarus will be won
because no one in the west wants that
the person responds i doubt there'll be
one brave again allegedly responds it
needs to happen i hope your people
understand this as soon as possible they
want to divide us and pit us against
each other later brave allegedly says
that quote civilians won't be hurt which
this person responds after explaining
that they are hiding in their bathtub
afraid of every loud sound we hear that
many have died already brave posted a
response to the screenshots about
current situation these screenshots are
from direct messages of me and ukrainian
girl by that time nobody knew what's
going on i just wrote my initial
thoughts and first impressions by that
time my knowledge were far from i
learned after because i wasn't out of
politics at all you can clearly see on
those pictures that i want this to end
asap and don't want people to get hurt
or killed later that day fnatic
announced brave was suspended pending an
investigation of the situation but even
without a suspension brave was not going
to be able to play in iceland because of
those visa issues while spray af has
been suspended from the roster pending a
current investigation it became apparent
to us beforehand that he would be unable
to attend masters due to visa issues and
circumstances involving international
flight from russia so right now we still
don't know the results of the
investigation brave is still suspended
for those alleged dms but no matter what
happens fee is going to be starting in
iceland but fanatic's troubles don't end
there remember earlier i mentioned durka
fanatic's star duelist well he's tested
positive for kovan 19. fnatic announced
the positive test on april 1st and said
that if necessary hyper would fill in
for him and to be clear this was not an
april fool's joke drikka said he's
feeling fine with minor symptoms but in
order to travel to iceland he needs to
produce a negative test as of writing
this script durka is still covered
positive so that's fnatic's situation
but that's just half of the story for
eu's reps in iceland see fun plus
phoenix qualified in really dominant and
spectacular fashion as the region's
first seed but on march 28th we all woke
up to the news that they would not be
able to compete fpx has two russian
players and one ukrainian player but due
to travel and coveted 19 restrictions
fpx will not be able to compete a riot
announcement said that this was no fault
of their own and that they were unable
to field a complete roster in reykjavik
in their place team liquid who
originally failed to qualify would be
invited since then fpx have been awarded
money and points they are still not
competing in iceland so after all this
where do we stand well eu is not sending
the teams they were supposed to sure
finnada qualified but they will not be
playing with the roster that qualified
and team liquid legitimately did not
earn a spot at this masters but at the
expense of another team have found
themselves able to play and compete eu
is arguably the best region in the world
going into iceland but no matter what
happens at masters there will be an
asterisk over the event let's say any
other region wins it wouldn't be wrong
to say well that wasn't the eu that was
meant to be there there wasn't the full
force of the region we will not be able
to really see how the best of the best
stack up because simply put the best are
not going to be there
you